[Música]
[Aplausos]
começo por convidá los a analisar por
durante alguns segundos as fotos que
irão passar na cra
peço que coloquem mentalmente a seguinte
questão com pontos comuns existem entre
as foi entre essas fotos
ignore as diferenças pensei apenas nos
eventuais pontos comuns entre elas eu
percebi ao longo dos anos que ter ousado
sair da minha zona de conforto da tão
aclamada zona do conforto entre parentes
será que a zona do conforto e sinto
confortável feijão sair da caixa se
formos perigos lá fora mas ter
descoberto também um mundo muito mais
vasto do que aquilo que eu tinha vivido
até então eu descobri o meu multiverso
pessoal embora algumas pessoas o chamem
de outra coisa
o universo pessoal porque nós todos
temos um universo muito nosso mas esse
universo já disse importa várias
realidades completamente diferentes se
pode multiplicar e tudo depende de
quanto usar o chairman dessa zona de
conforto
há uma história relacionada com essa
descoberta desse universo pessoal com
mônica mais ou menos três anos atrás eu
ea minha equipa no âmbito do projecto
kalunga só vamos se devemos seguir para
o namibe o parque do iona e fizemos uma
grande excursão
nós moramos cerca de setores mais ou
menos um vôo am de lisboa a transpor o
parque por crimes irão encontro de uma
tribo a tribo himba um subgrupo do zero
mais conhecida com uma tribo das
mulheres de vermelho nós criamos lair
por causa desse projeto
só vou falar a seguir porque queria
estar com eles seria a nossa primeira
experiência com essa tribo
queremos absorver tudo aquilo que eu
tinha para nos ensinar
eu estava secretamente obcecada com a
maneira como as mulheres dessa tribo
ornamentavam o corpo da mulher como a
maneira como elas pintavam apel a
maneira como elas vêm transávamos cabelo
estava completamente obcecada pela
imagem de força da ancestralidade que
elas transmitiam e nós chegamos lá e
fomos recebidos como qualquer
estrangeiro teria subido nós com as
nossas roupas acidentais tênis calças
gaga achar tudo muito muito diferente
muito estranho e havia que um certo
distanciamento entre nós
entretanto o membro da equipa sabendo
dessa minha obsessão foi ter com um
grupo de mulheres e disse que eu gostava
muito de conseguir encarnar um bocado
espírito inpa e quem sabe poder vestir
como elas
elas chamaram obrigado a observar com ar
muito sério perguntaram se eu queria
mesmo sentirão como elas eu disse sim
então e ela sabia frente toda gente
enfrenta toda a aldeia disseram então
deixe as tira a roupa não mas vamos
entrar para acabar letal para fazermos o
processo não deixa aqui então essa foi a
primeira prova de fogo
ali estava enfrenta total de enfrentar
toda a equipa
com esse desafio mas era o que eu
precisava de fazer para poder então
chegar a concretizar esse desejo como
sabotar a blusa e tal até porque tudo
pela arte não é tirar o sutiã e eu
sentia quase um caubói no texas em pleno
do euro mas com armas de grosso calibre
e acho que depois de tê-lo fé e tentar
mais ou menos orgulhosa de ter tido a
coragem de fazer
ninguém prestou atenção nenhuma ninguém
sequer olhou pra mim
homens mulheres velhos crianças aquilo
pra mim era algo tão diferente tão
inusitado presa era o dia a dia eu
estava exatamente igual às outras
mulheres
então pronto passei a prova entrar
banana skins um momento de
confraternização sem falarmos a mesma
língua e foi um momento absolutamente
bonito e de uma empatia extrema elas
ajudarão a despir ajudar uma vestir as
poucas peças que eu teria que usar
montaram o corpo com o oxigênio que é
uma mistura de oca com como manteiga que
é produzida por eles põem papel super
super suave tem a certeza que as marcas
de estética se descobrissem iriam
aplicar um creme caríssimo não tarda
quando eu saí da cabana foi o momento da
população pra mim pra eles primeiro por
toda a gente inclusive a minha equipa
com seu olhar para mim com olhos
completamente diferente quem era essa
pessoa e do governo porque eu começar a
olhar pra mim não como um estranho que
chega lá e tem curiosidade pela sua
cultura como muitos devem fazer mas como
alguém a quem sabe poderia fazer o parto
da tribo deus e aí fui aceito de uma
forma completamente diferente
começamos a interagir muito mais eu
podia pegar nas crianças podia a
conversar com ele de outra forma alguns
falavam português outros inglês
outros apenas o dialeto da tribo mas do
fato foi vale um momento de empatia tão
grande que eu nunca pensei sentir
passamos de investimentos por um momento
muito muito íntimo e foi de fato um dos
momentos em que eu percebi que é a
dimensão em que eu tinha vivido até ali
não era suficiente estava a funcionar um
multiverso pessoal quando cadu
eu desde pequena que eu tenho certeza
que queria ser advogada dirige toda a
minha formação acadêmica e profissional
nesse sentido toda a minha formação
acadêmica e profissional nesse sentido a
sua advogada sua jurista de profissão e
de fato posso dizer que sou uma pessoa
realizada essa desfeita com a carreira
que escolhi com perfeitamente ciente das
minhas responsabilidades na sociedade
enquanto jovem enquanto mulher e
profissional
no entanto não obstante isso a verdade é
que alguns anos eu comecei a sentir uma
certa em equitação uma exceção
sossegava alma parecia que aquilo que
estava a viver aquilo que eu tenho pra
dar
não era o suficiente havia muito mais
para dar
depois dessa dessas várias experiências
que o que eu tive a oportunidade de
bater eu parece que eu peguei naquela
imagem que todos nós já vimos em muitos
poucos na internet inspirador em que é
uma bolinha que diz zona de conforto
depois há uma outra que diz o lugar onde
a magia acontece e ficamos todos
embasbacados a olhar para um lugar onde
a magia acontece e pensar como é que eu
chego lá
passando essa imagem um carro
competitivo para nossa vida real a a
verdade é que ela está completamente
incompleta e é grande a verdade é que a
volta do tão grande no lugar onde a
magia acontece
existem muitos outros lugares os lugares
minados que dizem descrença frustração
de motivação bancarrota medo mas a
grande verdade é que nós vamos conseguir
desviar desses lugares minadas se
conseguimos escolher um bom caminho para
passar pra passar por entre as meninas
nos agarraram na beleza da jornada
chegamos então a vários pontinhos do
felicidade
há vários pontinhos da magia acontece
que não precisa de ser um lugar grande o
lugar principal podemos simplesmente
usufruir na jornada e não a surfar nem
vida descansada que button essa sensação
de missão cumprida
exatamente por ter isso em mente e por
algumas alguns episódios da vida não ter
ensinado isso eu disse lhe para tentar
acalmar essa inquietação para tentar
fazer com que a minha alma sugas um
bocadinho mais e para também que eu
pudesse perceber de que forma é que eu
poderia contribuir mais
eu decidi criar um blog ok dirão vocês
um blog é uma coisa super fácil de criar
qualquer outro time léo consegue fazê lo
em dois segundos mas a questão não é
essa não era o golden se eu precisava do
expressar pela escrita e para mim
a escrita é um ato de responsabilidade é
um ato que deus nos diz muda é um ato
que nos põe seu apresenta um texto
escrito por meio de todo o coração
ainda que tenha muito pouco talento
vou fazer um show apresenta um texto ao
ganhar um texto meu significa que o
apresenta completamente nua branco essa
pessoa e digamos receber críticas nestas
circunstâncias é um cadinho
constrangedor
entretanto depois de ter regressado
angola passado um longo período fora do
país
eu decidi com o blog que centra em
narrativas de viagem deveria focar-se em
angola deveria focar-se no país por
vários motivos primeiro porque estava
absolutamente cansada do que as únicas
notícias
as únicas coisas que diziam sobre o país
eram coisas negativas
isso não é verdade angola tem muito para
dar
por outro lado e por outro lado porque
sinto que nós que andamos pelo mundo
temos a obrigação e temos a obrigação de
sermos embaixadores do país de onde
vimos e temos que aceitar e assumir essa
responsabilidade e portanto eu assumi
desta maneira esta minha time da
contribuição para o país poder dar mais
poder falar deu poder apresentar uma
outra perspectiva sair luanda entrar
verdadeiramente na civilização entrar na
natureza e poder então sentir um
bocadinho do que são as nossas gentes da
nossa cultura as nossas tradições às
nossas raízes foi logo tem me dado um
prazer imenso passei a escrever para
revistas internacionais sempre a falar
sobre angola com muito orgulho com muito
sentido de missão no sentido comissão
que vem do coração e desculpem alguns
meses atrás do meu coração sair do lugar
e passou para esta zona
a grande verdade é que todos os dias
quando acordo penso mas o que é que eu
posso dar mais do que for me que eu
posso contribuir mais do fato ou várias
crenças e com foram prometidos passar
que fazem com que eu tenha tentado dar
um contributo maior a título de exemplo
tentei colaborar com os herdeiros do
etnólogo josé tinha uma pessoa conforto
pouca gente conhece na verdade mas que
foi como era conhecido como sobra saca
puma foi o primeiro único ele achou
branco em angola o único só branco da
áfrica subsaariana e foi o responsável
por definir a linguagem etnolinguística
da cultura shopping são pequeninos por
pequenos contributos mas na verdade eu
não estou satisfeita
nunca ninguém satisfeito eis que surgiu
um novo desafio um desafio para o qual
eu não estava preparada
tinha que partir outra vez e obrigaram a
sair da zona de conforto e sair do zero
para conseguir a para conseguir
corresponder mais uma vez esse desafio
que era a produção daquilo que agora é o
primeiro filme documental sobre certo em
angola ea questão que toda a gente
colocou é uma sul
a advogada vai produzir um filme pois é
vedado outra vez a partir do zero mas
sem medo de ser principiante
mas obviamente com muitos raios e
provocar minho mas então por que os ar o
site não faz parte da nossa cultura mas
porque essa temática dentre outras
porque isso não faz sentido a tão poucos
praticantes da modalidade em angola
então nós tivemos que explicar a todas
as forças à nossa volta os amigos a
família os players que poderiam ser
emprestados para o filme os potenciais
patrocinadores porque em primeiro lugar
temos que desmistificar a questão
o sar não é não é que não seja próprio
da nossa cultura o site não pertença
cultura nenhuma pertença todos os povos
à beira mar
existem inscritos do historiador cador
nega que remontam ao século 17 que dizem
esses relatos
por este historiador dizem que existiam
nativos perto da zona da barra do kuanza
que tinham uma prática rudimentar
parcial sars e utilizavam esta forma de
sair para poder passar a arrebentação e
chegar então as canoas
então aos arf não faz parte da nossa
cultura scaglia faz por outro lado
porque o desporto o desporto do facto
implica inclusão implica senso de
comunidade e os afinco em exclusivo está
ligado a questões ecológicas
há uma vontade imensa de viajar do
preocupações com a biodiversidade e
porque também a nossa costa a nossa
costa e privilegiada prática da
modalidade
nós temos 1.600 quilômetros de costa
angolana em grande parte tem um
potencial fantástico prática da
modalidade que é possível praticar ao
longo de todo o ano com uma onda
perfeita das mais compridas do mundo e
se eu pudesse explicar se eu pudesse
transmitir aqui que a riqueza isso é nós
andamos à procura bilhões de dólares um
sítio errado quando temos a lei toda uma
natureza ver todo o potencial turístico
brutal todo um potencial coda de vir do
desporto e advir dessa modalidade que
não está dando todo de todo de maneira
nenhuma ser explorado e portanto é uma
das coisas que nós quisemos demonstrar
com este projeto
por outro lado e pense que é importante
dizer isso nós começamos por utilizar o
site como uma porta de entrada para o
país
no entanto o país transformou
completamente as nossas voltas deu nos a
volta à cabeça intrometeu se o nosso
tema e fez com que o filme agora seja um
filme sobre angola um filme apresenta
muitas das vertentes da nossa
angolanidade e que na verdade agora
acaba por ser residual mendonça filme
sobre sá foi engraçado perceber que nós
pensávamos que estávamos a inovar a
falar sobre uma temática inovadora mas
afinal não estávamos estávamos a falar
sobre algo que fica aliás já está
enraizado na nossa cultura ea verdade é
que tentando ser vanguardistas o país
obrigou nos a recuar obrigou-nos a falar
sobre a austrália e dados sobre
indicações antropológicas
chegamos a conhecer um bocado melhor
norte a sul toda a nossa cultura está
presente no filme e que nos fez mudar
nós sofremos uma metamorfose psicológica
acredito que tenhamos passado pra
facilitou a nossa evolução pessoal
porque na verdade descobrimos um país
como os obrigo a ir até às nossas raízes
obrigou a recuar para depois dar um
salto para a frente serão os
verdadeiramente vanguardistas
depois de toda essa experiência foi uma
pensar
apetece dizer é rafa do rei mas esse
seria um plágio que é melhor fazer mas
eu não ponho a pensar isso nós pensar e
se nós pensássemos em motivar os
inquietos os apanhados aquele irmão
sonhador é que o filho está sempre a
fazer questões inoportunas é que o amigo
está sempre cheia de idéias nós
decidíssemos apoiá los e não chamá los
loucos mas se calhar poder poderá
passear as suas idéias e fazer com que
este mundo do fato pule hawass
como disse como diz o meu pai uma vez os
líderes tal como os artistas são sérgio
inquietos porque se não forem não
conseguiram mudar o mundo e nós com os
office a pensar no país numa forma
completamente diferente e então
recuarmos um bocado e percebemos que nas
nossas raízes
está tudo aquilo que nós precisamos para
seguir em frente
eu espero que com todas essas
iniciativas e com tudo aquilo que vai
dos anos do fato deixar essa sociedade
um bocadinho melhor pois filhos que
trazemos ao mundo eu deixo com vocês um
cheirinho dessa aventura que foi gigante
com carga de idéias muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ae
amor
[Música]
depois a bomba humana
ae
[Música]
apaixonar
ae
[Música]
o ator